hello everyone and welcome to a
remarkable game from yesterday's protest
League it's uh Croatia Bulldogs versus a
team called Blitz led by Maxima Shiela
grav missing a vid there and Alexander
grishock and this game is spectacular
for a couple of reasons for one uh the
brevity of the game it's only 23 moves
and it's really amazing how how the
Checkmate happens another thing uh
engineer's opponent is Maxima shella
grav who is uh pretty much a a legend
chess player he has been uh top 10 in
every time format in Blitz classical and
Rapid he is currently number six in
Rapid in the world and like I said he's
considered one if not the greatest
expert on the groomful defense uh the uh
opening uh that we will see in this game
so that being said let's check it out uh
and you know try to imagine how this
could have happened here indeed opens
with Ponte D4 we have Knight to F6 by
Maxine C4 G6 Knight to C3 and D5 we have
the groomfield defense Knight to F3 and
Bishop to G7 and here there are many
moves you can play at top moves or
something like Queen B3 Bishop g5c
captures and D5 E3 those are all uh
moves being played in the in the highest
level competitions and by by top level
players but here we have Ponte H4 now
it's uh not played as often but it's
still a very well-known move and the
maxim has faced it before and nowadays
it's 2023 you have to be ready for H4 in
pretty much any position so okay D
captures and C4 we have E4 and now comes
a move that
is very odd because Maxine did have this
exact same position uh even in a
classical game he had it against
mamadarov in the 2013 uh Bilbao Masters
the game ended in the draw C5 was played
in this position but here Maxim plays B5
and this is where the game really
becomes interesting we have Pawn to E5
of course as as black clouded now Knight
the D5 and this is uh probably where
Maxim mixed up his uh his notes because
here you should play Knight to G4 and
then probably after Knight captures on
B5 and day six Knight to C3 and C5 you
will try to punish white for still
having the king in the center of the
board and maybe I don't know maybe uh
okay you're done material but you your
pieces are more active and you should be
should be okay here however Maxine
played Knight to D5 and uh Here Comes
Knight captures and B5 castles and no
not even Bishop captures on C5 here
injiji just plays Ponte H5 we have Pawn
to C5 by Maxine and now Bishop captures
on C4 we have Knight to B6 attacking the
bishop and now uh here you would expect
unlike Bishop to B3 or even maybe even
Bishop to D3 to keep the bishop on one
of the two diagonals but Alexander goes
all the way back with Bishop to E2 and
Maxine should just consider a nice calm
onto A6 and then continuing development
but he plays C characters on D4 and this
is now uh too much to handle here
White's position is completely winning
and this is how Alexander does it age
captures on G6 H captors now comes
Knight B Captain D4 Queen to D5
activating the queen but um
uh doesn't uh doesn't do all that much
with Bishop to H6 stopping Bishop
captures on E5 so Bishop captures Rook
captures and now Bishop to G4 it seems
Maxim did get uh some development in and
that he perhaps could punish the white
king from still being for still being an
E1 But Here Comes Queen to D2 here
Alexandra sets a deadly trap and it's
impossible to avoid this trap you could
survive but only only for a little bit
it's impossible to survive the the game
in its entirety so here Knight 8 the D7
was played Maxim just continued his
development but here uh the position is
completely lost here injich has a forced
Checkmate in eight so feel free to pause
the video and to win the game for
Alexander while I give you a couple of
seconds
foreign
this beautiful Checkmate and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it is Rook the h8 uh I I know it Rhymes
but I mean it's not like I made that
happen so Rook to h8 congratulations to
everyone who found it uh and now the
problem is there is nothing you can do
if King to G7 then this is just mating
one the F6 Pawn prevents the king from
escaping uh so you have to capture the
rook and now comes Queen to H6 with
check only move King to G8 and now
Knight to G5 and how do you stop Queen
to H7 Checkmate well uh here Maxime did
try a few things he played Queen to A5
check King to F1 he even played Bishop
captures on YouTube with check just King
to G1 this okay you could also capture
but there's no reason to do it King G1
you can see that there are no checks
that black can give you know the
Checkmate is coming on the next move so
here Maxim tries Knight to F6 now he
covers the H7 Square e captures on F6
and he even plays Queen captures on G5
hoping for Queen captures on G5 and that
would maybe allow him to remain in the
game a little bit longer but here injury
just played Queen to G7 uh and this is
now Checkmate now it's incredibly rare
that we see not just um Maxim losing in
in his favorite opening the groomfield
defense okay maybe neither of is his
favorite opening but still Knight of fan
groomfield are uh he's like the the
absolute uh uh biggest expert on the two
openings and here injury just demolished
him in 23 moves uh you know just
absolutely merciless so it's a very very
hard to imagine how this happened but
now you see how it happened here in this
position it was B5 instead of C5 and he
probably had something prepared but it
didn't really work out for him and you
just continued with a very nice H5 uh uh
you know crash through the the black
King's defenses and then this
spectacular Rook to h8 just um ended the
game so brilliant game by engage against
uh such a top tier player like Maxine
versus I was pretty sure I added the V
there I have no idea why that did not
stick so sorry about that uh yeah there
we have it now it's Maxim vashir
yeah uh so I hope you enjoyed that and
the Croatia Bulldogs also defeated uh
Team Blitz as onboard one Alexander
grishuk was unable to defeat uh Bogan
and Daniel Dak so the the dead end draw
and I believe let me just check real
quickly uh yeah uh Paulina uh one on
board four or maybe it's not board four
because the boards rotate so just on one
Paulina one on one of the boards and so
they uh defeated uh Team Blitz with a
result of three to one so very nicely
done uh so there you have it that's how
you you crush the groomfield defense if
black plays weird moves uh I hope you
you're also able to do that in some of
your games I hope you enjoyed that I
would like to thank Glenn Glenn Beaton
Chris Foster and Bernard domrrani uh
funky monkey and ravishing reptiles
YouTube for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and what what else happens
in the Chess World thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day